des têtes d'affiché pour tous les styles
à la maurice de trappes la programmation
s'adresse à tous petits comme grands
amoureux de chansons françaises ou deux
fado notre public est différent certains
écoutent du rock d'autres du fado
d'autres voilà la musique du monde et je
suis du reggae
du rock de la chanson française donc oui
donc notre formation se destine au
niveau musical le plus large possible
les revenus de la musique classique
également c'est du côté de la musique
qu'on trouve le coup de coeur de la
programmation suzanne révélation de la
scène française qualifié d'incroyable
par la merise
[Musique]
je vous parie un poisson
série
lancer la saison précédente les goûter
spectacle sont remis au programme de la
salle trappistes il lance même la saison
2019 2020
le 5 octobre les spécimens présentent
une satire burlesque du monde du cirque
[Musique]
c'est une formule qui fonctionne et les
parents des enfants sont en demande donc
voilà ce qui est intéressant surtout
celles échanges et le travail qui est
mené
ce n'est pas seulement une diffusion il
ya un travail également avec les
familles qui viennent assister au
spectacle et après un échange avec
l'artiste et des ateliers et c'est ça
qui est chouette elle les habitués
seront aussi de la partie les solistes
de la villedieu et déclic théâtre rip
novo c'est la saison du cirque du
théâtre de l'humour mais aussi de la
danse les pokemon crew revient natra
pour une étape de tournée anniversaire
la compagnie fête ses 20 ans